vladimir putin is voted
russia's sexiest man alive daily mail
russian president vladimir putin the man
who was famously pictured topless
while riding on horseback and fishing
has been voted as country's sexiest
male a survey of 2000 russian men and
women found that the kremlin leaders
russia is the most
good-looking man in the country the 68
year old bachelor was the only man to
reach double figures in the poll
by job board site super job when asked
who
was the most attractive man in the
country 18
of men and 17 percent of women voted
for putin he insisted in 2018 that he
was not embarrassed about the topless
snaps
and said he has saw no need to hide
behind the bushes
while on vacation so adam i think this
is since you
really wanted this story yeah do you
think he is the sexiest man in russia
i mean i think it's hard to not see the
sexiness in vladimir putin and if you
don't disagree
don't uh drink that cup of tea that he
just provided you
because there's likely poison in it so
um
he's been the sexiest man in russia for
the last 20 years sexiest man alive
sexiest man a lot of six
there was a competitor but he's no
longer alive which means now
yeah his name is navalny that's right
he's in second place only for one
afternoon we took care of it
are you really traveling home today you
may want to drive home today instead of
traveling from here
and taking a flight because you you know
you don't want to call this guy
on a podcast he's probably listening go
go for it just so you know russian
valuetainment channels got nearly a
quarter of a
quarter of a million subs now and our
content being translated in russian is
doing very good and some of your content
is russian so imagine if putin's watched
one of your case studies
tom when are you flying back to dallas
uh a week from tuesday
it's so over the top ridiculous when i
keep the pictures up sam
when i think of sexy i'm not thinking of
a 68 year old
balding pasty white semi somewhat flabby
guy
that ain't screaming sexy to me so we
talk about competition
yeah this guy's got no freaking
competition by the way are you saying if
you guys got into a fight you'd beat him
up at 68. do you think you could beat
him up
i'm being serious yeah i'm looking to go
viral so yeah i'm challenging vladimir
putin to a one-on-one
horseback fight duel that angle you have
right now is not necessary go
okay that's better okay um no we we do
it better in the united states we have
better examples i mean this is
that's like basic this is the equivalent
of basically america being like
breaking news guys bernie sanders
sexiest man in america
that's the equivalent of what's going on
go to the site because
if he wants you to go to that site i
don't know what he wants you to look at
um let me show you how we do it in
america we do it a little bit different
okay got it this is how we do it in
america ladies
and gentlemen this is how we do that
sexiest for you
sarah palin well i'm saying to some
americans
okay go to the fake original what is
that the second one that's hilarious
we're gonna go to
that one that says fake and original
right there buddy it's on the page you
got nine options one of them says fake
original
go down there you go oh i see okay
they're just playing it's not even her
yeah got it oh it's not even for
somebody else got it it's fake fake news
you can go back to the other picture
with uh putin i will tell you this
it's like when putin runs for election
he gets 90 of the votes i think you guys
are missing the point
i think you guys are missing the point
listen here's here's the point and
hopefully this will make sense to you
do you remember the 90s what calvin
klein models look like
80 pounds they were cocaine heroined out
well especially the females
i mean it was just like what like heroin
sheik
moss there was a joke there was a joke
the joke was the diet coke and coke diet
yeah yeah am i supposed to be like
saying oh my
gosh she's so hot she's so attracted
look she's dropped
no and then you had
a different taste and flavor that showed
up back in the days with marilyn monroe
or sofia lauren we were just talking
about them earlier right it was a
different uh where you said oh wow look
at that
are you basically saying you're a fan of
sir mix a lot no that's not what i'm
saying sir baby
that that uh let him finish his honor
it's a
poetry there you know by what they came
up with i like big bucks
but i'm gonna tell you this but here
here's what i'm gonna tell you
to russia they value toughness
strength confidence swagger
you you fear it's a different level of
attractiveness like in you as a two it's
michael b jordan
it's dwayne johnson it's robert downey
jr george clooney matthew mcconaughey as
those guys right
well in russia they want guys like this
they want a guy to be tough
so in russia it may be that he is the
sexiest man alive
to a russian he may be the sexiest man
if ryan gosling and him went on a
catwalk
the room wouldn't be looking at ryan
gosling they would say
look at this guy you know what he said
right there you know what he's saying
right there you want a piece of me take
a look at that
yeah he's looking down somebody said hey
get off the horse really yeah
it's probably what people i like putin
that's what they're saying a little bit
of russian that i know so
there you have it so adam are you
satisfied we covered a story so do you
actually would you vote for if you lived
in russia would you be voting for him or
not i don't think i'd be vote
i don't think i've ever voted for
sexiest man or woman alive but uh if
they didn't
have your vote i think he is the
toughest leader alive today
that's what i would do well in my house
i won
sexiest man at my house 18 years running
oh you won in your household yes i did
18 years tom yeah that's pretty
impressive i forget about the pool boys
because you want to know why i'm
undefeated
i want to know why tom because you have
no
competition bro if you were had some
confidence so you're saying he's got an
element of yelling in his house i'm just
saying
yeah you need something like yelling
what's going on here so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye